okay hello everyone um so the first talk
of the Altima is by gas minbari of
competition in white networks first off
I wanted to thank the organizers for
giving me the options so my
collaborators I'll be talking mostly
about papers one three and four which
was primarily done with a bunch of great
folks Google brain named Lee jae-hoon
Lee Roman Novick Jeffery Pennington Sam
Sean holds Josh's old dick Sheila
ciaochao and also special thanks to Greg
Ganga Dennis R and Jerry hurrah at
Cambridge so I guess to start off and
maybe get some a little bit of
philosophy I think we're kind of we
would all agree that we're kind of in
this early stage of trying to better
understand deep learning and what one
typically might do in some field of
science theoretical science and trying
to understand what's going some
understand some complicated system is to
try to tease out at least empirically
phenomena which are some Universal which
one would want to understand and are not
to microscopic a question and then
theoretically when you don't have a
place to start you typically might take
limits of a problem in certain variables
which you think might be important and
then try to once you identify that limit
and try to solve it maybe trying to
study corrections about that or do some
sort of particulars and so that's kind
of that was where we began thinking
about deep neural networks we started
with thinking about networks that are
very wide so infinitely wide but let's
say the width is larger than anything
any other relevant parameter in the
problem and fix depth and I apologize
that this talk is mostly a survey of our
older work but hopefully I'll try to
point out maybe some interesting things
that you could walk away with and the
three points that we'll all try to get
through is that we want to try to
characterize randomly the randomly
initialized neural networks specifically
the distribution over functions that are
computed by such networks that are
Internet
why'd what happens when you train such
networks in a Bayesian setting focusing
on two specific cases of fully connected
really connected in convolutional neural
networks will then do some empirical
comparisons to neural networks that are
trained with that are finite width and
trained with some sort of stochastic
optimization and then finally I'll get
to stuff that is more recent
so describing networks again in this
infinite with limit after gradient
descent optimization which is
essentially the neural tangent kernel
line of results but focusing on what
happens in free space so a bunch of
previous talks have kind of alluded to
this what happens to the generalization
gap as you make networks wider and
certainly some earlier papers had
pointed this out I personally saw this
in a paper by been on a ship or a while
back now and repeated such experiments
for different kinds of architectures so
on the left you see an experiment that
looks at the general generalization gap
across a variety of models all within
one fixed family fully connected
networks as you make them wider and on
the right you have the same thing but
now it's putting test accuracy all of
these models have a hundred percent
train accuracy but you see that as you
make the either the size of the hidden
layer in the fully connected case or the
number of channels in each hidden layer
larger that you see an improvement in
the accuracy and so it's natural to
wonder what happens in the limit of
infinite width and this is kind of
setting this I will try to point out
though that I think these plots probably
require a little bit more subtlety and
how they're made and by the end of the
talk you'll kind of see that if you take
the in if you believe in the infinite
with result that there is some
discrepancy between finite width and
infinite with performance and perhaps
that really means that if one were to
make this such curves or study such
curves a little bit more in a nuanced
way maybe for particular families of
models choosing hyper parameters in a
certain way that you would actually see
that it would Bend down
certain points suggesting that there's
actually a performance difference
between infinite with and finding but
that's kind of where we're working
towards and also our starting starting
point this was a while back now which is
obvious in retrospect is that it's
useful to think about the functions that
are realized by neural networks and not
just take a parametric you which I think
had been and from my perspective had
been kind of the subject of discussion
that I had seen and these could be and
to end functions realized by the network
or functions realized by intermediate
layers but it's interesting to study
functions particularly in neural
networks where the parameters lack of
clear meaning and they weren't really
designed to be interpreted well there's
a high amount of redundancy and in
particular the first question we're
going to answer is like which classes of
functions are we biased towards as a
result of initialization and there's
going to be a simple very simple answer
to that which I think is interesting to
think about in light of like function
complexity so terms of count of number
of parameters the it seems that even at
initialization you have a function
that's very complex but in terms of the
class of functions that you're realizing
you're moving towards something that's
rather simple and in general I think
it's interesting to kind of move between
thinking about distributions over a
neural network parameters and
distributions over functions whether
that's at initialization or during the
course of some kind of training
so where we started with this again now
while back was inspired by a paper from
Radford kneeled from the mid 90s where
he had made a connection between single
hidden layer neural networks that were
infinitely wide and Gaussian processes
and yeah and the connection is basically
about the distribution over functions
that are realized by this such networks
so specifically let's say you have a
neural network which just has a single
hidden layer has fully connected to
Paula g4 right now and you have an iid
prior over parameters and you also need
to scale these parameters the prior over
parameters in a specific way so that
everything is well-defined so just as we
do when we usually initialize a neural
networks you need to take the variance
of these parameters to scale is like 1
over and r1 over the width so that the
variance of the output that you get as
you take n to infinity is order 1 but
let's say you have that set up and this
is the computation that the neural
network does and I'll use this to kind
of also introduce a notation that I'm
gonna try to stick to through the talk
so Z the variable Z is the pre
activation after application of one
hidden layer I is the index for a hidden
node X is the input and weights and
biases are W's and B's and I keep
sometimes the dependence on the input to
specify that we're looking at these
functions of X this is a computation
that is done and then Neil pointed out
that as you take n to be infinite that
the distribution on the output converges
to a Gaussian process and this follows
from the central limit theorem because
you're some of the range
so specifically to me concrete let's say
you take your weights to be your output
weights to be normal with mean zero and
variance which is again scaled properly
and biases that are mean zero and I'll
stick to mean zero priors for all the
parameters throughout this talk so all
the GPS custom processes will then you
want to compute the characterization of
the GP so mean here is easy and
everything is in this covariance
function K their superscript 1 means is
the layer index and if you imagine
plugging in this expression here you're
going to get a contribution from the
bias-variance contribution from the
weight variance and some function of X
and X prime so there is no attention
here to inputs and training just
generally wouldn't by randomly picking
equates yeah that's it's the prior over
so it's some neural network with some PI
over parameters and you know what is the
prior over functions realized for right
now but then you'll see you can say
something about the train that works
so that was what Neal did in the 90s and
then we asked kind of the same question
about deep networks so again the same
set up network has fixed depth fully
connected to apology IAD prior over
parameters with the pram with the
parameter variance is scaled properly
then the claim is of the distribution on
the output is also a Gaussian process as
you take the width to be infinite in our
original paper we didn't have a rigorous
proof of this we just argued it from a
sequential kind of perspective so like
by induction we know that z1 is governed
by a Gaussian process after you take the
first hidden layer to be of infinite
width and then you kind of repeat that
and if you that's kind of maybe it my
good very hand wavy way to argue it but
then the claim was that Z was governed
by some Gaussian process with some
kernel K or covariance function K that
we need to compute so that was in our
original paper and there was a paper
that appeared simultaneously also by
Alex Matthews publish and I CLR that
proved the same statement rigorously and
you don't need the sequential limit of
taking you can you can also prove it
when the minimum of the layer width also
goes to infinity so it's it's been
proven more rigorously since then both
by Mathews and a later paper but so
given that the thing that you want to
now characterize is the mean and
covariance function and so this
covariance function denoted K to the L
as a function of input X and X prime is
just this expectation imagine plugging
this in you get a contribution from the
bias-variance contribution from the
weight variance and then you just need
to compute this expectation of these two
files of the pre activation signal
that's coming in for these two different
inputs X and X prime given that the Z to
the L minus 1 the signal that's coming
in is governed by some Gaussian process
with covariance function which you know
so this looks a lot of like a lot of
notation but it's just a 2d Gaussian
integral so we can kind of characterize
the result
in this one boxed equation which is that
K to the L is a function of X and X
prime is some function C sub Phi which
only depends on the choice of
non-linearity and it also depends on
what comes in the covariance function K
to the L minus 1 and you also have this
base case before you apply any
non-linearity which just amounts to
computing inner products between the
inputs time so we summarized this
description of the neural network that's
infinitely wide at initialization by
saying that Z sub L is governed by this
GP means zero covariance function K to
the L and symbolically this is the
recursion relationship satisfied so
again still working at initialization
you can ask about properties of this GP
sometimes I'll refer to it as the NN GP
to say it's the gas and pasta that
corresponds to this neural network
so these covariance these recursion
relationships have appeared in the
literature before and another setting
not connected to Gaston processes so Cho
and Saul for instance have earlier work
where they essentially define these
compositional kernels or calculate
defined it in this way and then
calculated it for Lu so it turns out you
can get closed-form expressions for Lu
for this sort of thing and also for
certain other activation functions and
you might ask for instance what is the
structure of this covariance function
and this is one plot that kind of shows
it so this is plotting it's a 1d plot of
X and X prime that are two vectors where
X prime is rotated by angle theta from X
and so you know before you apply any
non-linearity you just have a dot
product so X dot X prime looks like a
cosine and then as you iterate that
through a certain number of layers that
covariance structure gets bent in a
certain way and that's the flattening
that you see here with the depth so that
flattening or loss of structure is
something that you'll see comes again
excuse me as you as you iterate the
recursion relationship and so now to
return to the earlier question given
that you map the problem on to a
Gaussian process prior it's kind of a
textbook result - then do Bayesian
inference with such a prior especially
if you're just gonna do it for with
squared loss and the nice thing about
Gaussian processes is that if you tried
it if you do Bayesian inference you can
just ignore parameter space all together
and do it all in function space so these
integrals that are in principle over
these infinite dimensional vectors are
reduced to just integrals over these
function values and 4-squared loss all
of the the entire integrand integrand is
just one Gaussian so you can do them
exactly and the result you get is that
the output the distribution on the
output Z star given data set D and test
point X star it's given by a normal
distribution with mean mu bar and
variance and so this just reduces the
problem of doing Bayesian inference to
doing linear algebra you just have to
compute these covariance matrices on the
data set which is size n by n you have
to invert them and take various inner
products with the target vector and this
other portion of the covariance function
of the test point against data set and
so you've just removed all of the
optimization or integration that you're
going to do you're just going to do in
your algebra so in our original work one
of the things we were curious about was
if you
empirically compared the result of
implementing Bayesian inference using
this neural network Gaussian process how
would that compare to the result you
would get from training a deep network
at finite with some with some variant of
gradient descent and because we wanted
to do an apples-to-apples comparison
between the two so we were using
because we were we wanted to do an
apples-to-apples comparison between
Bayesian inference with the squared loss
we also trained on MSC when we were
doing greedy so these are the results
I'm going to show here are not
cross-entropy neural networks where we
know the networks do especially well but
the neural networks that are trained
with gradient descent all hyper
parameter optimized we tried different
nonlinearities different learning rates
different kinds of optimizers all within
the fully connected to apologies and for
the kernel computation we either
computed it in closed form where we had
where that was available for particular
non-linearity or we use numerical
interpolation for that to the interval
that I showed earlier for nonlinearities
where we didn't have and we implemented
Bayesian inference which requires that
matrix inversion in the data set size
which is quite costly in the data set
size we do that exactly and so these
were the results we got when we back
when we did them they're not very great
test performances but at least you see
that along each row there's a comparison
between the type of test set and the
size of the training set and then there
are four comparisons neural networks and
GPS and when you what's the best of the
four in a row is highlighted in bold and
you can see at least that although their
performances are not great that
typically the GP does as well as or
better than the neural network in
general the widest neural networks were
the ones that we're doing this and this
goes up to the full data set size which
Percy far
as an aside we also studied the
performance of these of the N ng P so
using Bayesian inference using just
linear algebra as a function of depth
for different nonlinearities so the top
row shows tan CH as the depth of the
network or the depth of this recursion
relationship that you iterate to is
increased and the bottom is for Lu and
the best performing networks are the
ones in purple and what you see is that
as you iterate with depth that the best
performing networks are concentrating
along particular lines or curves and
that has to do with what I alluded to
earlier where you saw that with depth
you were starting to lose the structure
of the covariance function because you
don't have you're not connected to the
input signal anymore you're just
iterating the same thing over and over
and it turns out that these sorts of
recursion relationships at least
asymptotically what depth had also been
studied before and in a different
context where the idea was that maybe
looking at fixed points of that
recursion relationship was a proxy for
good train ability for networks so you
can imagine that like it's some estimate
where if I'm losing the structure of the
covariance function meaning I'm losing
the structure between two different
inputs X and X prime then maybe I don't
have enough information to train and
those are regions of hyper parameter
space in this case just a
two-dimensional space of the weight and
bias variance that I should try to avoid
and so previous work kind of known under
the name of mean field theory starting
with these two papers had studied these
recursion and relationships with depth
and identify different fixed points and
also she kind of studied the length
scales over which you start to approach
this fixed point and the idea is that
you don't want your network to be much
deeper than that length scale because
that's kind of the character
characteristic scale over which you've
lost the signal between the inputs and
my
and so that those curves kind of line up
with those fixed points computed earlier
precisely because we're kind of thinking
about the same quantity and iterating
and then finally another experiment or
comparison we had done was to look at
the comparison of this n n GP against
again these finite width neural networks
as a function of increasing width and
training data set size and again now you
see it summarized here in a slightly
different way that the n n GP tended to
do as well as or better than the
best-performing neural networks which
were typically the lightest which are
the ones shown and so to conclude this
part kind of what we walked away with
from this original paper was a compact
description of deep fully connected
networks in the infinite with limit both
at the level of the prior so now it's
kind of easy to see that you're biased
towards a very simple class of functions
and then you also have in hand at least
four squared loss like an explicit
Bayesian posterior for this limit and
then numerically we had seen that it
seems that with SGD in the fully
connected to apology that you were
performing about as well as
you have to do MCMC then yes that's
right and because we didn't really have
expertise and that we didn't do the case
of like cross-entropy
it was about loss the choice of loss
like cross-entropy
versus square loss so that's why we we
didn't do that yeah so we didn't do we
only did really regression and like
classification performance here is kind
of just choosing so it's regression to
the one hot targets because we didn't
know how to do we didn't really have
expertise and that also and we were we
were worried about like what
approximation or how not being able to
do the Bayesian part exactly and then
with the trade-off but I expect there
that like will cross entropy is a good
loss and that's where you're you might
see the lawyers I'll come back to this
maybe towards then but you might see the
largest
but at least for the for this topology
get seemed like a didn't and it seemed
like it wasn't so was the case for fully
connected we then moved on to
convolutional networks so again you now
you just take the channel dimension to
be infinite and in this first paper
which i won't really go into we studied
this signal propagation field theory so
like what happens asymptotic leave with
depth but i'll focus mostly on this
paper which is where we do kind of flush
out this quantity neural network
correspondence and then repeat the same
set of experiments comparing with filter
rosacea the weights which responds to
did like these under a year prior and so
excellent so did
essentially what's worsening here the
differences in that customer and the
[Music]
expectation I guess that could be one
way of viewing it but maybe another way
of viewing it is also so we did have
regularization ads a hyper parameter in
there I believe that sometimes it could
be zero but I wouldn't say but a
different perspective is that like
what's happening with gradient descent
is really ntk at least quote like as you
make it wider so maybe it's also a
comparison between those two
but yeah I I'm not I'm not positive
tonight
with
yeah so we repeated basically that same
set of experiments for the convolutional
case gonna walk through that and so just
to work through what the covariance
function looks like for the con case so
and also introduce a little bit more
notation so now the pre activations
after layer L have this channel index I
but they also have a spatial index alpha
as a function of X and they depend on
the input X right now we're just going
to do one D spatial indices but we have
to keep track of both I and alpha and
this is the Constitution you have with a
con filter so here Omega to the L IJ our
output input channel indices beta is a
spatial relative spatial index and so
the Greek letters here are all tracking
what's happening spatially and so
similar set up let's say your parameters
are drawn iid where you have the weight
variance that weight variance of the
filters against scaling with one over
the channel size and I apologize I went
from little end to begin here but then
the claim again and we have a more
rigorous proof in this paper this time
is that is the number of channels
increases the distribution over output
functions is governed by some GP and now
we just need to compute the covariance
function and so the covariance function
now is this object K to the L alpha
alpha prime which depends on two inputs
X and X Prime so different spatial
indices and imagine plugging in this
expression here you get a contribution
from the bias variance and then this
expectation here where you do a little
bit of spatial averaging over beta so
that's kind of the effect that weight
tying has you're kind of blurring along
alpha alpha prime and to summarize that
let's just write it as some function C
which also has spatial indices here and
it just is shorthand for doing this
second moment calculation given that
what's coming into that layer is also a
Gaussian process
so this is just for pure covariances
pure convolution it's after a certain
number of layers with cnn's you have a
lot more architectural design choices
which makes it more complicated but
let's do two main ones that I'll focus
on two kinds of and choices of end
aggregation into ten output classes
which will give us two kinds of two
different kinds of Gaussian processes so
the first one is where we do the
following so we take the output here
it's this Z to the L of X and we like we
have both a channel index and a spatial
index we flatten it over both indices
together and then we just apply a debt
and we pass it through a non-linearity
and then we apply a dense layer this is
the W final IJ and this sum is over the
product of those flattened indices which
is channel and spatial information and
so this is again some GP but now the
covariance function if you were to
calculate it basically requires that
both the channel and the spatial indices
match so then what you get is just a sum
over the diagonal pixel elements alpha
alpha rather than different pixel pixels
mixing like alpha alpha prime which
would be a more general thing so in this
particular case when you terminate in
this way you lose the covariance the
turning different spatial locations and
also an observation from the previous
slide is that the spatial diagonal
continues to map to the spatial diagonal
so that's all you need to keep it all so
that means that the computation of this
covariance matrix will be
computationally easier because you have
fewer indices to keep around but what
you lost in this limit is also the
effective weight tank so you could have
gotten the same result if you had just
considered locally connected networks up
to that layer locally connected meaning
you have filters that still have some
small size to them so there's a spatial
they're spatially restricted but they're
not weight tightened across different
spatial locations so if you had just
done that and then terminated in this
way you would have gotten the same core
function so you kind of lost the
effective wait time with this kind of
termination and then the other
termination that we consider is one like
in its most general form is one where
you take the signal and you project it
onto some vector spatially so now alpha
is project you've projected with some
vector H alpha and sum over alpha and
the case that we I really just want to
focus on is the case of global average
pooling where you just sum over all of
alpha together first that's what you do
let's say you alpha index here over the
entire image and then you just need to
apply a dense layer to the channel index
and if you do that the covariance
function you end up with is written down
here so you end up mixing different
spatial locations because you did this
average pooling before you you did this
application of a dense layer and so you
have this sum over alpha alpha prime
which as you can kind of maybe guess
gives you a richer covariance function
because you've had some coding you've
kept some covariances between different
spatial locations so this is one kind of
empirical comparison between the various
nng piece and i won't discuss all of
them but maybe just highlight a couple
so one is the fully connected case which
we talked about before this is also for
a small training data set size which is
why the accuracies are so low so as a
function of depth that's the brown line
here the fully connected case the green
one is the case I described to where you
just have pure convolutions and you have
a dense layer where you flattened
everything so you see that there's a
little bit of a gap between fully
connected in that case but then there's
an even larger gap to the yellow line
which is the case where you do
convolutional pure convolutions and just
do global average pooling at the end so
that better covariance function and you
do see a gap in performance between
those two just as an aside like for some
of these things we don't have access we
didn't really track
the exact covariance function so there's
a version where you could write down the
exact recursion relationship and compute
what what you get and then sometimes for
to have access to to make it
computationally easier to have access to
a different class of architectures we
sample the covariance functions an
average over different instantiations of
the random networks so that's just an
aside as to what the MC means here and
that introduces some kind of
approximation which I won't really
discuss only and we haven't really
studied in a lot of depth but at least
even from a purely architectural
perspective
you point you see that there's a gap
between the average pooling and the case
where you just flatten and apply it does
that's a good question I don't have it
for this I think but I have it for I'll
show a table at the very end which has
all the comparisons and that will be
better and so there are certain so
another way to view some of the data is
that if you looked at certain
initializations and then looked at what
happens is you increase the number of
channels so this is part of your
question but again for small data set
sizes you the red lines are the GP and
the blue lines are the neural the finite
width neural networks as you make them
wider and in certain case depending on
how you choose these initializations
sometimes you observe this but then when
you like kind of aggregate over all of
the all of the hyper parameters that you
have including learning rate different
activation functions and such you find
that there is a gap between the CN n the
finite width neural CN NS and the GPS
and that's kind of summarized in this
table I want to maybe point out work
through some of the or walk through some
of the the rows so the bottom row is the
case of the fully connected networks
which we talked about earlier and we
repeated some of those experiments and
again we saw that the GP was actually a
little bit better in this case so this
is
this is test Aaron now I apologize
rather than accuracy but this was FCN is
just a regular neural network over opt
hyper parameter optimized over with
depth learning rate and batch size but
all for MSE and that's the FCN GP this
row here is the CNN GP just with a dense
layer so with no pooling and I won't
maybe I'll come back to what's in
parentheses but if you just look at the
numbers that are not in parentheses
CNN's with small learning rates or with
certain activation functions like Earth
kind of fall in the same ballpark as the
CNN GP but then CNN with rel you and
large learning rate does have a
noticeable gap that gap could come from
a variety of like places it could come
from finite width it could come from
relevant large learning rate effects
with gradient descent it could also come
from the fact that maybe the termination
that you did at this infinite which
limit was not a good one and so here we
already see this gap even though this so
this is just a gap for MSC loss already
between the kernel some kernel limit
which is not quite be the right kernel
limit because this predates us knowing
about n TK and that line of work earlier
but you see some gap and then the best
case is like a CNN this is finite with
CNN with average pooling and that was an
experiment that for the GP case we could
never scale up to do the full dataset
sides to make that comparison so we
guess that there - there would be quite
a bit of a performance gap this is maybe
to be contrasted or compared with the
recent paper by a group at Princeton and
I think maybe p.m. CMU where they do ntk
for the kind of case implemented exactly
and there they get better performing
they get better performing kernel
but that's because they're looking at
the case of pooling where we know it's
better and that was an experiment that
we were never able to implement we just
on the full dataset size at least we
implemented the density but there they
also see some gap that's of order five
or ten percent with networks and
that's a question so maybe I've
mentioned this like what's the intuition
about different political white and
puddings could have different we haven't
studied it in too much up apart from
that like having more information across
different spatial locations it's good I
we haven't kind of dug in deeper to see
how it's reflected saying the spectrum
so and we haven't considered more
complicated cases where you put in
pulling in inner in earlier layers and
also see what effect that has and this
was just to two cases
so so what that guy's to cases are one
is where you have pure conf
but you just flatten over channel and
spatial index and then you apply a dense
layer and then you your covariance
function there loses the alpha alpha
prime and then the other is where you do
fight the global average pooling at the
very end
so maybe a summary of this part so for
the fully connected apology we didn't
see much of a gap even for MSC loss for
kaan we did and then given that like
Bayesian inference in this limit it was
simple to describe we started to wonder
if we could say something about the
distribution under gradient descent also
in this limit and that was kind of the
question we walked away with after the
fully connected we worked on the fully
connected and then GP and in the interim
other people actually solved this this
question open question so in can you say
something about the behavior of gradient
descent or a gradient flow in the
infinite with limit and the result I
hope I might have I hope I didn't miss
any references but Jason talked about it
this morning very nicely was that I you
evolved according to some frozen kernel
which is the NTK and I this this slide
is now a little bit redundant in light
of Jason's talk in the morning
maybe the one takeaway is that when you
think about this parameter to function
space kind of transformation this this
quantity theta T which is the
generalization of like n TK kernel it's
just this defined to be the derivative
of the function map with respect to the
parameters contracted over all
parameters it's in general some
dynamical variable and to think of this
as kind of a special dynamical variable
that governs what's happening in the
network is I think one interesting
takeaway that's useful even outside of
the n TK limit so thinking of this theta
T as some damn
I will skip kind of reviewing what these
results actually are about so just if
you calculate like the gradient the rate
of change of the parameters and the rate
of change of pre activations that
internal layers for a specific hidden
node you see that they vanish and the
width going to infinity limit and so the
kernel as a result of that is frozen I
will point out that like this n TK
kernel is that the N NGP kernel plays a
role in the antique a recursion
relationship as you would expect just
because the n NGP kernel is coming from
essentially gradients with respect to
the last layer weights it's just this
covariance of the final features of
features in the final layer so that's
theta L is K to the L which is the N ng
P plus some other stuff which also
includes the n ng P in it because you
continue to use that every time you
calculate these expectation values you
assume that the pre activations are
drawn according to an image and you
start with this base case where theta
naught equals scalar this also mostly
skip so we had been working on some work
trying to understand what dynamics
occurs in parameter space given that
this dynamics occurs the NT key dynamics
occurs in function space without maybe
fully knowing the extent of results that
were already out there and so as Jason
mentioned in the morning n TK is
consistent with the linearization of the
model about the initial set of
parameters so just doing a first order
Taylor expansion and plugging that in as
a substitute for the network and that
becomes an exact thing to do as with
goes to infinity and something that was
also pointed out in other papers
including the ones that I one of the
things you can get out of that get with
that are for instance that the
predictive distribution over the model
output C star given some test point
extra on data set D
is this normal distribution with a mean
and variance that again involves the NT
kanan also involves the N and GP kernel
K and this changes with time as you run
gradient flow and we also had some
empirical comparisons between for
instance if you looked at the mean
prediction over an ensemble of say
hundred networks for say like a linear
1d linear interpolation between two
points which are the two points shown in
black you tend to see that well there's
a variance prediction coming from this
result there's a variance prediction
coming from an energy P and then there's
one that you can calculate on this
finite size ensemble and you see that
that variance is well described by NGK
fluctuations of the prediction and I'll
refer you to the paper for more
experiments so we basically did a bunch
of comparisons I'm still not
state-of-the-art models or anywhere
close to that but between wide neural
networks with no approximations and
they're linearized versions so maybe one
footnote to that is that these are
comparisons between not the exact kernel
and infinite width but just the first
order Taylor approximation which is
itself like random features method with
a finite number of random features so
that itself has some approximation in
general like when the data sites size is
small when the learning rate is small
when the network is wide enough there's
better agreement this is maybe the best
one we had in that paper where it's
something it's a network that has MS you
loss its ResNet like and then it has
like bachelor murmur Lu and cons in it
but it's all it's everything is wide so
every there are no restrictions on the
channels they're all like of order a
thousand and it's a comparison between
the neural network trained with MSP loss
on the full C 410 data set against its
linearization and you can see that so
that's a comparison between the solid
line and the dashed line and you can you
can see that basically
late times you start to see the
deviation but at least up to a certain
accuracy there's an agreement between
them - and this was like the largest
data set sized thing that we had push
these experiments up to so maybe just to
close part of basically what I talked
about was trying to have a full
characterization of what happens to
neural networks add infinite with
whether you take a Bayesian approach or
train with gradient descent we have
descriptions both in parameter space and
function space I talked about at least
where loss like a description in
function space I didn't say anything and
nobody's kind of really put work out
there yet on what happens in parameter
space in that same limit but maybe we're
we're pretty close to kind of completing
this table at infinite with so I will
say maybe then in closing that although
I think probably state-of-the-art
architectures which have restrictions on
the number of channels that they use
will be far from being described by ntk
dynamics there are networks that are
very commonly used
maybe not for actual performance reasons
but certainly things that we use in
papers to do Theory comparisons for for
instance fully connected networks maybe
with MSE loss which might be kind of
have the performance of something you
could get with the kernel so that's
maybe one takeaway from this and then I
think also that even if like dynamics is
not well described by the finite width
neural network and the kernel there are
pieces of that that could still have
impact on other things so for instance
just like signal propagation or
trainability a lot of that might be
invertible from studying the ntk kernel
and then also like are there kernels
with impressive test performance I don't
think we've really searched the space of
these kinds of compositional kernels
anywhere nearly as thoroughly as we have
searched the space of neural networks
and current work in progress which I'm
happy to chat about offline is trying to
understand Phi and understand
gasps between Angie
[Applause]
all these caution processes which are
somehow related but not exactly the same
thing so especially so my Enric I I'm
not super familiar with this but my
understanding is that in those models
they usually put a restriction on you
could think of it as a neural network
which has restrictions on the width in
particular layers and they do that
precisely so it doesn't collapse to a
single GP they say that it's kind of a
composition of GPS I think it's maybe
interesting to think about that as a
prior poster to like but they're they're
different in that all of these were like
networks that have all the layers pretty
wide with no bottlenecks in the size of
their
so if you do this high dimensionality
space then what you're doing is you are
colonizing into the still there just has
in Sandy two correlations between these
variables which are much harder to
extract no one can see anything the
information theory census hasn't changed
that's an interesting comment I mean do
you think that maybe those are important
than they especially had finite width
they stay and maybe they're important in
how
[Applause]